[Music]
your personal companion robot my what i
was issued by star command to ease your
emotional transition after your time
away oh well that's very considerate of
you robot feline but no thank you i'm
afraid it's protocol
sensors indicate you've missed four
birthdays would you like a frosted snack
cake to celebrate negative that would
compromise my nutritional regimen
we can talk about your feelings i am an
excellent listener no no look i've had a
very long
day
it did not go as planned the mission was
unsuccessful
affirmative oh no i am so sorry to hear
that
thank you sucks
you're welcome buzz
shall we play a game no thank you are
you sure i can create a game
specifically for you based on your exact
personality profile hey listen socks
buddy i'm pretty tired so i'm gonna go
ahead and hit the rack of course
i can provide sleep sounds if you like i
have several options summer night ocean
paradise whale calls no no white noise
is fine very well goodnight socks good
night buzz
[Music]
buzz lightyear mission log stardate 3901
after a full year of being marooned our
first hyper speed test flight is a go
who are you talking about uh no one you
were narrating again i was not just
doing the mission log you do know no one
ever listens to that i know that
narrating helps me focus
ready captain light you ready as i'll
ever be commander hawthorne this is
exciting a new adventure i'm gonna grant
you four minutes to be off planet but
then you come right back to us
to infinity and beyond
and you are clear for hyperlaunch
buzz that was utterly terrifying and i
regret having joined you
buzz lightyear to star command come in
star command
why don't they answer hey the robots the
what
what is happening right now
alicia oh no that's my grandmother but
sucks how long were we gone yum yum yum
yum yum 62 years seven months and five
days what
i hope you're ready for action because
all we needed was a pilot for what to
destroy the alien ship
i have a plan and i have a team darby
can take any three things and make them
explode
i do this and they shave a little time
off my sentence okay and what about you
well i thought this was going to be like
a fun boot camp workout thing
but it is not
did i get it pretty close i need the
anyone saying the harpoons
[Music]
the probability of survival with an
inexperienced crew is 38.2
seems a bit low
mission failure imminent in three
grandma always said she believed in you
too
there was a big swelling too i think i
need a bed at least record your last
words do not vomit inside the vehicle
if you are satisfied with this recording
speak or select one
[Music]
to infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that
sorry it's the thing your grandma and i
used to do yeah
[Music]
so
[Music]